[Music]
we are setting off on a journey fraught
with dangerous notions eternity the
creation of all things from nothing and
dare I add er it a word not to be thrown
around with reckless abandon among those
reason infinity a case in point of the
library of Babel it is a library that
holds every book that has ever been
written and every book that ever will be
written now here lies the madness each
book is filled with random strings of
letters 26 letters commas periods spaces
and each book is different but every
volume in every one of these galleries
has 410 pages each page has 40 lines
each line has 80 letters X alias that is
nothing but chance so for every sensible
line of straightforward statement there
are leagues and leagues and leagues of
senseless jumbles and incoherences for
example one volume is made up in its
entirety if the letters M see these
perversely repeated from the first line
to the last
another is mostly filled with gibberish
until you reach the next to last page
when you see oh time thy pyramids it is
unbearable knowledge that in some
gallery on some shelf a precious cogent
book exists yet remains inaccessible and
though one cannot know my belief is the
library stretches - dare I say it the
infinite
many say I'm mistaken that the possible
number of books does have a limit and
while that number is beyond my
understanding
I am gladdened by its distant hope that
however improbable I may one day uncover
meaning
[Music]